[Music]
there's something out there waiting for
us
how do they know man
[Music]
[Applause]
i was excited about telling a predator
story in a different time
and it is this creature's first time to
this planet
and there's great rootability watching
someone who's made their own weapon and
seeing how are they going to use those
things to take down something with alloy
and laser advantages
this is the david and goliath story
[Music]
the very first predator set the bar for
all future franchise films
so it gives us some of that backstory
and also the indigenous survival
this version of the predator is very raw
and powerful
it really fits inside of our world
it knows how to hunt
[Music]
i know how to survive
[Music]
why do you want to hunt
because you all think that i can't
i saw a sign in the sky
i'm ready
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
there's something out there i'm talking
about
you can't i'm trying to protect you
protect me from what
[Music]
it's time
[Music]
[Applause]
uh
[Applause]
it knows how to hunt
i know how to survive
[Applause]
[Music]
i can kill it
[Applause]
[Music]
you